what's going on guys today we're going
to be theorizing how things would have
changed
if molly had won during season one of
attack on titan as many of you know the
main conflict of the series started
when the warriors began their mission to
steal the fanning titan and we've seen
on many many many occasions how they've
come close
but couldn't quite finish the job for a
variety of different reasons in season
one
five years had passed since mali's
initial attack but everything began to
change when aaron was revealed to be a
titan shifter
this reveal had countless repercussions
that we saw play out including irving's
suspicion that there were more shifters
in the military and the mps arguing with
scouts to determine who gets custody
looking at things from a marlin
perspective aaron being a titan was a
great thing
because now the warriors had a tangible
target they needed to capture of course
they didn't know for sure that he had
the founding titan
but at this point all three warriors
were just desperate to return home so by
capturing aaron at least they could
bring back something
annie in particular wanted to return to
mali to see her father again which is
why she ambushed the survey corps during
the 57th expedition
after a lot of running and a lot of
fighting we eventually got to this
moment where she destroyed the attack
titan
and this is where i want to begin from
for you manga readers watching this
video
let's assume this is a totally alternate
universe where anything can happen
and for you anime only viewers there
won't be any spoilers because like i
said
this is an alternate reality don't
forget to colossal smash that sub button
as we are on the road to 300k
and also drop a like if you want to see
more content like this
okay so we're picking up immediately
after annie defeated aaron in their
one-to-one fight
which occurred in a separate area of the
forest to everyone else the only reason
mikasa is there is because she heard
aaron scream and turned back
and the same is also true for levi who
arrived not long after she did
everyone else was told by irvin to
withdraw from the forest and get back
into formation
but the goal being that they return home
without further casualties
now going back to annie with aaron in
her mouth she would now be attempting to
escape the forest and the ackermans
would not be far behind
in the main timeline levi was easily
able to defeat the female titan
but suffered an injury in the process
due to him protecting mikasa
in this new timeline the only way i
think annie could succeed is if the
captain somehow isn't able to defeat her
and the only realistic way that happens
is if his injuries are more severe
for argument's sake let's say that in
this split second when levi is reacting
to the pain
annie follows through with her attack
and sends him flying towards the tree
behind her
that should kill a person but levi being
levi i'm sure he'd do some kind of quick
maneuver
that only results in two broken limbs i
know ervin was able to use odm gear with
one arm in the main timeline
but in this case levi has broken both
his left arm and his left leg
making it significantly more difficult
while mixer is an amazing fighter
she showed earlier in the battle that
she's just not on levi's level of speed
meaning annie now has the extra time she
needs to harden around her nape and
mouth
with his injuries the captain would no
longer be in fighting shape but he'd
realize that mikasa is not
going to defeat the shifter by herself
therefore his orders would be to return
to the group
as collectively they have a much better
chance of saving eren by joining with
the rest of the scouts you'd have great
minds who could think of another plan
and other strong soldiers who can help
out trying to take her down after he
calls out to her telling her to come
back
she would no doubt refuse to leave at
first but with enough talking i'm pretty
sure he could convince her to fall back
mikasa would carry levi in the same way
that he previously carried her whilst
using odm gear and i don't think this
would be hard because look at him he
probably doesn't weigh that much
while the two acumens leave the area the
female titan would still be sat down
slowly continuing to regenerate
as aaron remains inside her mouth flash
forward to outside the forest
and these two would have joined up with
everyone else and urgently informed the
irving of the situation
the commander would know that without
eren there is no point in returning home
since his titan powers are the key to
reclaiming will maria by losing eren
you also lose the best chance of
defeating the titans hence why i'm
certain everyone would put everything on
the line to get him back
instead of retreating the new planets
for the scouts to quickly ambush the
female titan as she exits the forest
levi will estimate where she's going to
come out based on her previous path
with miko zakarius adding his support
since his sense of smell allows him to
know when titans are approaching
the cervical would then move out
immediately and they'd be following
levi's directions as he's being pulled
along in the cards
inside the forest itself the female
titan is continuing to regenerate
but is taking longer than usual due to
her tiredness by this time in the day
annie had been sprinting and fighting
for significant periods
somewhat showed that levi already
noticed she had slowed down with her
being in this state
we should ask ourselves how exactly is
she planning to return back to mali
the answer is actually pretty simple but
in order to explain it we must flash
back to when the warriors first arrived
on parodies
in the source material mcgath told them
that the malian army would be anchored
on parodies at the full moon
this scene was excluded from the anime
but what it means is that once a month
when the full moon is out
a malian ship will be at the wharf
waiting for the warriors to arrive
this was confirmed to be true during
season 2 because when the full moon
appeared
zeke peak and the malia military arrived
on the island that same day
as such annie's plan right now is to
return to the wharf with eren
just in time for the ship's arrival
within a couple days when looking at the
map
there is still a huge distance between
where she currently is and where she
plans to go
but luckily she won't have to do this by
herself reiner and bertolt are among the
scouts heading to intercept the female
titan
yet unknown to everybody else they are
secretly working with her
remember when annie first appeared she
attacked the scouts from the right wing
because that's where reiner informed her
that aaron would be of course aaron
wasn't there since reiner and burton
were given false information
but the point is they are trying to help
her catch him with the attack titan now
in annie's possession
these two will do whatever it takes to
make sure the mission succeeds
this is unlike the main timeline when
they didn't get the chance to defend
annie because of where they were
positioned
had they made a move back then they
would have given away their identities
without a guarantee of success
but this situation in the new timeline
is much more favorable
moving on the scouts will continue to
move around the forest in the direction
levi instructed
however they would soon hear an insanely
loud scream coming from within the trees
naturally this is the female titan using
her ability to attract pure titans and
it works even quicker this time around
because many of them are in the forest
already
even though she's tired the female
titan's size and endurance means she's
able to outrun the titans behind her
at least so she's able to make it to a
safe location annie would call them to
act as insurance
since this horde could deal with the
survey corps if they try to ambush her
again
right now her goal is to escape the
forest and reach malmaria at which point
she'd use odm gear to ascend the wall
with aaron in hand
once on top of the wall she'd have the
rest of the day to properly recover
without worrying about the titans on the
ground
and then when it's night time she'd
begin the journey to the wharf at this
particular moment annie doesn't know
when or if her fellow warriors are going
to make a move
so right now she's planning to do it by
herself but if they join in then
obviously that would be a big help
after hearing the female titan the
cervical would keep going but this time
in the knowledge they'll likely have to
deal with pure titans as well
commander ervin would therefore have to
think of a new strategy and based on his
risk-taking nature i have a solid idea
of what he would do
earlier in the day the scouts had two
weapons able to subdue the female titan
the first being the cannons and the
second being captured levi in the
current situation neither of those
options are available
so urban would plan to use a small
amount of pure titans to stop her
instead
the idea is that once the female is out
of the forest the elite scouts will cut
her down from the legs which is a
realistic goal considering what already
happened
what the commander would want is for a
select amount of maybe three or four
pure titans
to attack the female while she's down
since eventually that might force the
person inside to come out
the commander knows the female can't
maintain her hardening permanently
so it's guaranteed that she'd have to
exit the titan along with aaron at some
points
the main gamble of ervin's plan is that
he's relying on the scouts to not only
cut any down
but also restrict the amount of pure
titans that reach the female titan
if too many get her then clearly aaron
and annie could actually be eaten
so the fate of humanity rests on how
effectively the scouts can kill those
other pure titans
anyway mikey alerts the scouts around 10
seconds before the female titan appears
with the elite group getting ready to
attack at this moment ryan and bertolt
would no doubt be sharing nervous
glances
since it's really all or nothing if they
choose to help annie then the plan
better work because they won't get a
second chance
on the other hand if they think they
won't be successful then they'd rather
keep their identities a secret so they
can capture aaron another time
reiner in particular would be feeling
incredibly nervous and conflicted due to
his split personality
meaning for once berto might be the one
who has to make the hard decision
the female titan then emerges from the
forest intending to head toward maria
as usual i'm sure annie would have one
hand protecting the back of her neck but
the skill of this group would be enough
to chop her down
a few seconds later titans also start
pouring out the forest with commander
irving giving a roaring speech to the
rest of the scouts
likely something about the fate of
mankind or something like that people
like jean and armin would head towards
that threat whilst mike joins in to
provide backup
mikiset and the commander would stay on
top of the female as she slowly crawls
along the ground
with one or two pure titans starting to
approach the female's body
irvine would warn the person inside that
their only option is to either reveal
themselves or get eaten
but he promises that if they come
quietly with eren then they won't kill
her
these words from owen would definitely
be sincere because he knows whoever is
inside
this titan likely has valuable secrets
that he wants to learn
in the back of his mind though the
commander would be wary if the female
could transform again for a third time
but due to her tired state he's
cautiously optimistic that she can't
a small group of pure titans then start
eating the female's legs it is now that
mikasa gets really desperate and shouts
her to let eren go
reiner and berto remain relatively close
by watching this whole thing unfold
since they would have volunteered to
guard the injured cat to levi i imagine
butter would be heavily sweating at the
sight of the female's body being eaten
while ryan looks like he's about to
vomit or cry or maybe both
and he continues trying to fight off the
titans and her erratic movements make it
so that mixer and irvin have to retreat
back down to the ground
probably close to where reina and berta
are standing in her hopelessness
the female looks over and makes direct
eye contact with reiner which visibly
shocks him into action
he'd reluctantly take a step forward as
if he's going to rush in to save her
but at the same time he hesitates due to
his conflicted mind this gets the
attention of irvin who asks if reiner is
feeling okay
but berto covers him by saying that he
just really wants to get aaron back
this is when the moment of truth occurs
since in the background annie punches a
few titans away to give herself some
space
billowing smoke then emerges from the
nape of the female and out of it we see
annie emerge with aaron in her arms
until now the commander was the main
person who suspected there were titans
among the 104th cadet corps
but to people like mikasa this reveal of
annie being a titan would make no
sense even with her desire to save eren
she'd be seriously confused right now
meaning the first person to take
initiative and move forward would be
irvin himself
the two other warriors would follow
immediately behind the commander and
with titans crawling closer to annie and
aaron she would shout out to rainer for
help
i believe this has to happen since annie
is in a desperate situation
and the armored titan is best suited for
quickly grabbing her up
of course everyone in the area would be
taken aback by this with irvin turning
around
to see winery behind him with a newly
determined look on his face
before any scout could reach them the
warrior stabs the commander in the back
prior to biting his hand and
transforming into the armored titan
as that's happening berto would have
sped ahead to reach annie
and you know he just asked her if she's
okay and check if aaron's breathing i
guess
now as painful as it is to say commander
ervin would die
in a situation like this reiner cannot
let him survive besides being the brains
of the survey corps
he was also the first person who was
going to reach annie and the warriors
couldn't risk what might happen next
for all the warriors no the commander
could have decapitated annie straight
away before grabbing eren like they just
don't know what's about to happen
so the only guaranteed way to save her
is to kill him by transforming into the
armor titan
irving would be finished off by titan
electricity which is something that's
happened to several people in the main
timeline
bertolt and annie would then use odm
gear to jump onto the armored with
reiner shielding his friends as he
sprints further into titan territory
at this moment each member of the circle
would be feeling a mix of grief disgust
and confusion of what they just
witnessed
but levi would remain the most composed
ordering what's left of the scouts to go
after aaron and avenge the commander
one thing i should point out is that
unlike the main timeline yamir has not
yet been revealed to be a titan shifter
and i don't think she would be her main
goal right now is protecting krista or
historia
and unlike season two she's not had time
to strike any kind of deal with the
warriors
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below but in my
opinion she'd keep her cards close to
her chest
and not reveal her titan form inside
reina's hands annie would have told her
comrades about the plan to rest on top
of the wall
but obviously they need to lose the
survey core before they can do that
out of the three shifters they have the
female has the best endurance for long
distance running
so it's essential that she gets this
recovery time before they start the
journey to the wharf
when it comes to getting rid of the
scouts the colossal is the only weapon
they have that can do this quickly
however annie is skeptical if berto has
the balls to kill off his friends
she probably tried to backhandedly
motivate him in the same way that reiner
did in season three
and hearing this from his crush berto
would probably be like yeah i can do it
i reckon eventually he'd come to the
same realization he did in the main
timeline
which is that he knows the scouts don't
deserve to be killed but he has to do it
anyway because the world is just that
cruel
with the cervicor in hot pursuit the
warrior's new plan is provided to throw
bertot towards their pursuers
and then the colossal will do a
controlled explosion to wipe them out
remember back in season 3 he was already
going to blow the place sky high without
any negotiations
and the only reason he stopped was
because he saw reiner was hurt
after that armin tried to start peace
talks like he always does but in this
new timeline berto is at the end of the
line
he just wants to go home and these 10 or
15 scouts are the only people standing
in his way
for that reason he follows through with
the mission and after reiner throws him
he blows the remaining survey call
members to smithereens
yes mikasa armin levi and whoever else
are beloved characters we love them very
much
we don't want them to die however in a
realistic alternate timeline
there's nothing they could do to avoid
something like this if they're chasing
after rhino on horseback and then rhino
just turns around and throws bersalt
well what could you do at that point
it's like realizing someone's about to
shoot you after they pulled the trigger
but then it's just way too late
in this alternate timeline the warriors
end things before they reach wilmaria
with the colossal being trusted to
deliver the finishing blow
in terms of what might happen afterwards
for a start i think aaron would lose his
mind realizing he's been betrayed
since he had no idea these three were
titan shifters the main timeline shows
us that aaron is always the last person
to believe it even when presented with
evidence
but in a situation like this he can't
deny the truth rhino would likely cut
off his limbs to stop him transforming
and i doubt they'd tell aaron any
information about the outside world or
about the deaths of armin and mikasa
i say this because it's crucial they
don't aggravate aaron more than
necessary
since they don't know for sure if he has
the founding titan or not and whether
he'd hypothetically be able to use his
power
rather than poking the bear too much it
would be safer to keep their cars close
to their chest and not reveal any
unnecessary
information to their new prisoner they'd
begin their journey to the wharf that
night
and make good progress switching between
the female and armored titans
no doubt they'd reach their destination
within like 24 hours making sure no one
gets eaten this time around
upon arriving to the wharf i imagine the
situation is not how aaron imagined he'd
see the ocean
and he'd break down crying given the
tragic circumstances he doesn't know if
armin is even alive because the warriors
aren't telling him anything
and you know given his limbs are chopped
off and he's being taken god knows where
it's just a very unfortunate situation
zeke and peak would arrive the following
morning
and from that point on the main priority
is getting aaron back to mali
we all know the oldest yeager brother
has his own secret plans to euthanize
the eldean race with the power of the
founding titan
but the warriors don't really know if
aaron has that titan like i said
not even aaron himself knows he has the
coordinate so zeke has very few options
right now
the only realistic way to find out which
titan aaron has is for zeke to touch his
younger brother but he can't risk doing
that because you know if he does it then
eric could destroy the world or do
whatever he wants
this therefore presents an impossible
situation physique if he doesn't do
anything
then he knows aaron will be eaten once
they get back to mali but on the other
hand if he does do something and touches
eren
his younger brother might gain the power
to destroy the world given the
uncertainty around aaron's abilities i
think the malian ship would likely
return straight back home
but maybe they'd still conduct a quick
experiment on the citizens of ragako
beyond that they have no reason to stay
on parodies any longer and aaron would
be brought back to the malian continent
immediately
in the short amount of time they'd have
before poco eats the attack titan
it's nearly impossible the jager bros
would work together like they did in the
main series
even if zeke managed to convince him
they were brothers aaron still has very
few reasons to help
guys known for five minutes to sterilize
the aldian race
maybe you could have a situation where
he plays along but secretly plans to
betray zeke
however the time frame is so short i
feel like zeke wouldn't fall for it
because aaron would just play along way
too quickly
as a result in this new reality galliard
does end up eating aaron and unknowingly
inherits two shifters in the process
whether mali then goes back to parodies
depends on whether they can ascertain if
poco has the founder
from the beginning molly's goal was to
retake the founder for itself so if
gallagher has it then they can go to the
island and wipe it out
and also steal its natural resources
however if they can't work out that he
has it
then that makes things a lot more
difficult let me know down below what
you think would happen next
especially when it comes to zeke because
i kind of doubt that he would be able to
convince porco of his euthanization plan
as always thank you guys for watching
this video and be sure to hit that sub
and like button if you want to see more
stuff like this
until the next one peace out